emaciated and weak but found alive after
spending more than a month wandering the
Amazon jungle in the first pictures
released their scene with some of the
Colombian soldiers and Indigenous
volunteers that have been searching
restlessly for them for five weeks since
they survived a plane crashed deep in
the rainforest on May 1st
president Gustavo Petro said finding
them was nothing short of a miracle
the military forces and the indigenous
communities that helped with the search
efforts found the children 40 days after
the plane crash the children were on
their own they are an example of
survival that will go down in history
today those children are the children of
peace and the children of Colombia
the children aged 13 9 4 and 1 year old
were recovered near the border between
the kaketan guavyare provinces close to
where the small plane had crashed their
mother and other three adults died in
the accident
relief from their grandparents after the
news of the rescue was announced
[Music]
we are happy now because this situation
hasn't allowed us to sleep or be happy
we couldn't walk for us it's been like
living in the dark we walked for the
sake of walking lived for the sake of
living but the hope of finding them kept
us alive when we found the children we
felt joy we don't know what to do but we
are grateful to God
the faith of the children moved the
country and Drew Global attention a
massive military-led search operation
involving over a hundred Colombian
Special Forces and 17 indigenous Scouts
swept the area around the clock
helicopters used loudspeakers to play
messages from the children's grandmother
in their native language survival kits
and pamphlets were left in the jungle
but for weeks only Footprints a dirty
diaper and a baby bottle were found
but the search teams never gave up until
finally finding them alive a truly
extraordinary outcome to a story that
has kept the entire country in suspense
for more than a month Alessandra Al
Jazeera Bogota